hi everyone Joey here again with another
unboxing for you this time for the
persona 5 take your heart premium
edition now this thing usually goes for
$90 but right now it is sold out
everywhere but if you're still
interested of the game we do have the
review up on gamespot.com so go check
that out
the meantime plus open this up see
what's inside nice I will try to be a
little bit more careful with this one
then I did with me Hills near automata
box last to go yeah this does not belong
to me belongs to our own jean-luc slide
that off and this box so it's all the
characters none of which I know the
names of I actually don't play persona I
feel like I'm the only person in the
office right now that does not care for
this game but there is a bunch of stuff
that I could care about so first thing
we got is a little Hello plush is the
Morgana plush we also got fairly large a
nice art book for the game right here
it's called a persona 5 art book the
aesthetics that's a white so we got I'm
not sure how spoilery this art book goes
in so I can just go like really quick do
it there you go nice book open it up I
can unwrap it
sure
[Music]
describe everything about the plushie
warnings this project is designed for
ages 17 and up do not bleach this
pulling may cause smaller parts to
become permanently detached do not place
under direct sunlight or near heat as
discipline coloration may occur project
is flammable so do not place near heat
sources shoot all right next up we have
a 705 sounds of the rebellion official
soundtrack including tracks such as wake
up get up get out there doubt ominous
interrogation room and it is a say day
we don't scratch inside ok this is fine
then there we go it's in there looks
very much like the next up well let's
see what we can own bugs
oh here let's just do the actual case so
the the game here it does come with the
game believe it or not so this is the
steelbook version yeah it's there it's
uh has a little nice red color going
around the edges inside actual disc see
what it has here no instruction manual
lots of warnings but there is some nice
arts gonna take out the CD here with
some nice art on the inside
[Music]
this is from the Fujian Academy
looks like bag this is right there this
is a looks like a just a duffel bag to
put your persona 5 take your heart
premium edition on the inside inside
there's a little plaid pattern you got
there so this is very uh school ready so
we can take all of our stuff that we
just box first day of school ready to go
alright and that was everything that was
in the persona 5 take your heart premium
edition now if you just got the game and
you wanna know more about it make sure
to check out our video of the 9 things I
wish I knew before starting persona 5
and if you want to see more unboxings
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and leave a like
I'll see you next time
[Music]